nuevo acto de violencia política en
Brasil durante la campaña electoral hoy
una defensor del presidente Chávez
bolsonaro de 22 años ha sido arrestado
por haber matado a un apoyador del ex
presidente Lula aconteció el 7 de
septiembre el día de la independencia de
Brasil en mato grosso un estado del
interior de Brasil los dos discutieron
trabajaban juntos cortando leña y Rafael
Silva de 22 años mató a su víctima
usando un hacha y un puñal no es la
primera vez que acontece un bolsonarista
en julio mató al tesorero del partido de
los trabajadores en foz de iguazú en el
sur del país al río de aquí en bolsonaro
ambos eran policías y la víctima estaba
celebrando su cumpleaños en una fiesta
caracterizadas con fotos de Lula y hoy
aquí en San Gonzalo en la periferia de
Río de Janeiro ha habido un acto de los
ricos a favor de la izquierda en el que
el propio Lula ha comparecido un ex
candidato municipal aparecido con un
coche con fotos de Lula entre rejas ha
habido una discusión y finalmente un
militante de izquierda ha agredido al
provocador la cosa no he ido a más pero
se teme que la violencia electoral vaya
escalando a medida de que se acerca la
fecha del 2 de octubre